so you're either an architect or an
architecture student looking for a
laptop in what i'll call
late 2020 early 2021.
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here on this channel we
review technology and talk about
all things architecture related if
that's something that interests you make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below
and let's get on with today's video
today we're talking about the best
five laptops for architects and
architecture students
in 2020 now i haven't put a budget on
these products because of the simple
fact
when you purchase a laptop for
architectural purposes
chances are you're going to need to
spend a little bit more than you think
especially if you want them to be able
to cover all the programs
and all the different software that
you're going to be more than likely
running throughout your career now
before we begin it is in my personal
opinion
that laptops in an architectural
profession do not last
or keep up with technology for more than
three to five years
so after three to five years you're more
than likely going to have to
update your system and either sell your
old one
get a new one or figure out how to be
able
to upgrade to the latest and greatest
technology
that's because technology moves at such
a rapid pace that it will leave you
behind
and you will not be productive with an
outdated machine
so with that being said let's get into
my top five
laptops for architects in 2020 in no
particular order
number one is the microsoft surface
laptop
three it's the product you see behind me
and it is my personal laptop of choice
however to be able to run this machine
on all
accounts that you need to be using it
you're gonna need to spec it out which
means
an i7 processor 212 gigabytes of storage
at a minimum
and 16 gigabytes of ram the reason i've
selected
the surface laptop 3 over the surface
book 3
is predominantly for price i've again
selected the surface laptop 3
over the surface pro x for the simple
fact that the surface pro x has a mobile
chipset inside it
and doesn't have the graphics
capabilities to run programs like
archicad revit rhino 3ds max
or any other rendering software you
might think of so this machine behind me
will set you back
approximately 2 699
australian dollars or the equivalent of
1889
us dollars so that isn't exactly a cheap
laptop to be purchasing however i've had
this device for a year and a bit now
the surface 4 is about to come out in
this month
if not sooner so it is definitely
a good time to be buying this towards
the end of the year
the surface laptop 2 as well is a
phenomenal device i've used that in the
past
it is able to handle pretty much
anything you throw at it
it does render a little bit slower than
the desktop behind me does
but that's expected being a mobile
laptop device
moving on to the competition the apple
macbook pro
this is the second laptop in the top
five category at no particular order
the unfortunate thing with apple
products is if you are planning on
running
revit you're going to need a virtual
machine or some way
to run windows on your computer if
you're running archicad then you're all
set basically from the get go
max in my personal experience i use one
at work to run
archicad and they are phenomenal there
is
no issues running archicad on a mac
computer as long as you get
the right computer from the start so for
example the product behind me
if you wish to use it for architectural
purposes you're going to need to get the
2 gigahertz quad processor version
with a minimum of 512 gigabytes of
storage
if you do need more storage on any of
these devices i always recommend
onedrive because i tend to use a lot of
word excel documents and the sorts which
can be quickly and easily accessed on
all tablets and all devices and edit it
as well
the macbook pro is a little bit more
expensive than the surface laptop and it
comes in at 2999 australian dollars
or the equivalent of 2199
us dollars now for the simple fact that
i have both of these machines directly
behind me for you
guys to interpret and view in this video
i think deserves a quick
smash of that like button to help this
video with the youtube algorithm
third on the list is the dell xps 13
13-inch model
now this one has its pros and cons like
the surface laptop 3 it has an i7
processor
512 gigabytes of storage and 16
gigabytes of ram
unfortunately it has a shared graphics
card having said this
it can definitely do the job but the
materials and the quality of the device
are a little bit lackluster considering
it's 3399 australian dollar price tag
this is equivalent to approximately 2420
usd for that money you basically get
a plastic shell whereas with both of the
devices behind me
you get a nice unibody aluminium case
that is robust rugged and feels like
absolute quality
for both of these devices being cheaper
than the dell xps
again i'd pick one of these two over the
dell hands down any day
now we're moving up into the world to
the more cad workstation
purpose-built computers these are in my
personal opinion not the prettiest
things
but they do the job and they do the job
very very well
i'm going to read this one straight off
my ipad because being an msi
it has a very long name number four on
the list is the
msi wp65 10th
dash 1210au i know tongue twister the
benefits of this device over the rest
is the simple fact it has a 15.6 inch
screen
none of the other devices listed so far
have been able to compare in that
department
however personally speaking i find the
13 inch screen
more than enough for the time to time
that you need to use a laptop
most of the time you will be working off
a desktop so it is
always advisable to get a custom built
desktop and then a supplementary
laptop if you can afford both of them
the msi features also a shock horror of
an i7 processor 512 gigabytes of
storage and 16 gigabytes of ram this is
a purpose-built cad machine so you'll
get
some better processing power on the
technical side of things and on the
rendering aspect
when you need it however it still will
not be able to compete with a desktop
so don't go presuming just because that
it is a cad machine
purpose built that you're going to get
those sorts of specs out of it
it doesn't matter if you go and spend 10
grand on a laptop it's still not going
to be able to compete
with a purpose-built top-of-the-range
desktop besides the fact this device has
a 2899 australian dollar price tag
or approximately 2100 usd it is
extremely chunky extremely clunky and
weighs a ton i wouldn't really
personally want to be lugging it around
in my backpack
all day every day especially as a uni
student where you already have a whole
bunch of stuff that you need to carry
all the time so this is a great computer
if you're looking at using it as a
workstation potentially as a
supplementary
to the desktop if not your primary but
it isn't exactly the most ideal travel
companion
now the fifth and final is the most
expensive by far
and it is the thinkpad x390
yoga this device is a convertible
two-in-one touchscreen device
that has a whole bunch of features that
everything else does as well
just like the rest of the devices it has
an i7 processor 512 gigabytes of storage
and 16 gigabytes of ram the added
benefit of the 512 storage here is a
solid state drive
which if you don't know what a solid
state drive does basically it loads
everything
significantly quicker than the old
school drives it also incorporates 65
watt
fast charging through a usbc outlet
and has a very corporate design we'll go
with
i guess because in the last company i
work for everybody had a thinkpad
it was the standard issue across the
board and
they were okay they were the intro
models they definitely weren't this
and i personally wasn't a fan of their
design but
hey the design isn't everything this
device is able to
handle anything you need from revit to
archicad
once you start getting into some very
large scale projects with some demanding
objects inside them
you're probably going to see some
shortfalls in all of these devices
but out of all of these devices i think
the thinkpad and the msi are definitely
going to be able to stand up to most of
what you throw at it anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
i hope it gave you some insight into
what laptop you should be looking at
purchasing
as either an architect or an
architecture student in 2020
if you enjoyed the video please smash
the like button down below to help this
video grow with the algorithm
and hit the subscribe button if you want
to see more of these videos
thanks so much for watching and as
always i'll see you next monday